sorry i missed that how old are you a
call has just come in from someone who
says they were at school when pressure
to get married first began
you absolutely do not deserve to be
being treated in this way
this is the helpline for the
yorkshire-based charity karma nirvana
we've been given access to their cool
logs for the 12 months up to september
in an extract from a conversation with a
health professional an operator was told
a sibling is concerned that because of
the shame she has been told she has
brought on her family her seven-year-old
sister may be married off
in another case a social worker told the
helpline the eldest daughter is 14 years
old this year they took her to pakistan
to get married the 14 year old is
adamant that she wanted to marry
and a call for help came from someone
who said about a family member she
became engaged when she was 12 years old
and then had a religious marriage just
after turning 15.
many of these issues because they happen
in minority communities we still find
that professionals are quite fearful to
tackle or address the issues
and there's a degree of normalization as
well when the call came that a
seven-year-old was at risk
what went through your mind
shock i think the shock that this can
still happen
a bill is being presented to parliament
to raise the age of marriage in england
and wales from 16 with parental consent
to 18 and the coercion of children into
marriage to become an offense rather
than the child having to raise the alarm
the vast majority of child brides are
married off in community or religious
ceremonies
this is the face of a girl who got
married at 16 and bridget wall now
separated says it was too young
when you're married from the traveling
community at 16 that's when you're
considered an adult
it's just too you're too vulnerable
you're too vulnerable and it just should
be illegal bridget gave us a rare
insight into the travelling community
claiming she'd heard of around a dozen
cases in england in the last year of
priests blessing 14 and 15 year olds
seen in her community as the equivalent
of marriage
basically they think that it's find them
because they have a blessing they have
to live together and she can't come home
she cannot come home because she has
slept with this boy
and no one else will have her
some of bridget's social media videos
raising awareness have had more than a
million views
traveller groups have told us failing to
engage with them over changes in the law
risks children being taken into care and
they have not been sufficiently
consulted
in west yorkshire we met local
councillor habiban zaman who works on
women's issues she told us she believes
young people are mature enough to make a
marriage commitment at 16.
that is concerning if it is below 16
but anything above 16 you know i think
if if the young people feel that they
want to enter into a marriage then
that's fine if we're imposing a legal
age on
their
um their marriage or their queen's
ceremony
then it's it's leaving it wide open to
abuse because you know they will do
whatever they want to do behind closed
doors
campaigners hope the private members
bill will lead to the biggest overhaul
of marriage laws in a hundred years lisa
holland sky news